as far as the eye can see on this rural
mountain side the people of paktika
province are left digging grave after
grave
after grave
this is devastation like afghanistan has
never witnessed before
48 hours on and still no comprehensive
rescue operation
instead desperate villagers in this
remote region plow through the rubble
with their bare hands to find some life
but as they dig through the destruction
they find only more bodies
more casualties at the hands of this
catastrophic earthquake
in this house 35 members of my family
were martyred among the dead bodies of
my sons and grandchildren
we ask the islamic emirates and the
whole country to come forward and help
us
we have nothing not even a tent to live
in
despite trickles of aid into the country
through planes from iran and qatar the
government here are still pleading for
international support
but this is a country that has been
isolated since the taliban took control
last year and that much-needed response
doesn't seem imminent
the taliban state representative in
islamabad said wealthy nations should be
quicker to respond
this is a human rights crisis and those
who criticize the islamic emirate of
afghanistan are human rights violations
themselves
isn't it a human rights violation to
deal with a different country's natural
disaster or human rights crisis
politically
a lot of aid agencies that we've spoken
to has said that countries may be
hesitant
to come and give support in afghanistan
a country that's ruled by the taliban
what would you say to that
in this beginning i don't agree before
this many countries sent assistance to
afghanistan
for example the united nations has sent
money and aid
the current situation is more critical
than ever before and we expect more from
the international community
whether there are larger diplomatic
reasons at stake or not on the ground it
is everyday afghans who bear the brunt
it shouldn't be any condition attached
to humanitarian imperative to saving
lives and it is about saving lives and
it should be focused on you know
announcing monies or funds uh looking at
equipping humanitarian organization
which much more so they can deliver on
on the ground
as time goes on hope for any survival
diminishes
afghanistan is well and truly reeling
from this powerful earthquake and its
people need help urgently intimate
rasheed sky news islamabad